am i writing to Jamie that one of the
reasons why this story could have
resonated with you is because you're
your own father was in this you know
it's personal when Michael called me up
I was so humbled and honored to be a
part of the project but doing this right
is personal being a black man and and
the perception of us in America is that
we've already were guilty of a crime and
I could personally touch it because my
father they put my father in jail for
$25 worth of illegal substance they put
him in jail for seven years this man was
an educator in the hood in the inner
cities educating kids the judge that he
would have come to the school and talk
to the kids presided over his case and
put him in jail and then what they
didn't understand was their father
taught me everything taught me how to
throw a football of basketball
taught me how to play tennis why am i
learning how to play tennis he's because
I don't want you to be limited so me as
a young black kid in Texas some of my
childhood heroes were Vitas Gerulaitis
ilie Nastase Yannick Noah
Yvonne Linda so when they put him in
jail however what do we do as a family
and I don't like visit in jail I don't
like that type of perceptions and so I I
said I told my pop sighs I can't come
see you cuz I see you as a king but I
wrote him I wrote him a letter I said
hey you know things have gotten good for
me when you get out I save your life and
he's been living with me for 20 years
now
and here's a good part about it he loved
tennis so I got a chance to take him to
the US Open when he got out and we
watched Venus and Serena play and we sat
there and then tears ran down her cheeks
but when he got a chance to see this
movie he said you tell that that young
brother Michael B Jordan keep doing what
he's doing cuz this is so important for
us yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you